[Music]
my name's child gave her I'm knowing our
child fans fried chicken in Harlem New
York fried chicken
it's not a social and I've been cooking
chicken it's just out eight years old
and I always cook my chicken in the
frying pan
my mother she taught me how to cook
chicken and she told me you know if I
open up a bid to this day never frying
the deep fryer fry my chicken in the
frying pan and cooking in the frying pan
is better than cooking in the deep fryer
we taught your chicken is more crispy
more juicy and not oily fried chicken
and you know you have to really
concentrate because you got to keep
turning chicken in the pan so therefore
you can't take your man off of it
because if you do you're burning you
really got to pay a lot of attention to
it you're gonna cook it in a frying pan
[Music]
first you you'll get the whole chicken I
use whole chicken you take off the wings
then you split the chicken down the back
then you take out the sin of rest then
you're gonna take off the side breast
and then you're gonna take the thigh leg
you're gonna cut it separate the time
delay which give you nine pieces of
chicken then once you do that you season
it I got certain things that I put in it
salt pepper onion and a few more things
that I can't give up just sprinkle it on
not too much just a little chicken and
rub it and you just let it sit and after
that I can make up your egg wash with
milk and egg and I put a little bit my
special seasoning then I go into the egg
wash into the flour I use all-purpose
flour
now you just sees me also you don't want
to put too much in the egg wash you
don't wanna put too much in the flour
otherwise they're gonna be too so I get
into the frying pan
are you soybean oil because soybean oil
don't burn its fat to some dogs out
there you don't want to cover the
chicken oil you want to be half in half
out and then that's all comes about
I'll say 375 then you drop the chicken
in let it brown for about six minutes
then you turn it you got to keep moving
it and moving they're moving it
otherwise you're gonna Brown it if you
cook it too fast
on the side you have to cook it really
on the medium heat I would give it at
least 15 minutes and then what you want
to get golden brown you put it in a
drain tray and just let it sit there for
a minute
let the SS all go down and he's ready to
eat I used to sell chicken by the pop
that was a lady she came by and asked me
she said what are you gonna do in the
winter
I don't know tell you what I have a
truck emoji B so I took the truck and
you know I had a little route that did
every day so a lot of people they
couldn't catch that Whitley because I
moved I didn't stay in one spot that's
it you know what maybe I show up a
restaurant and you know everybody come
in say you got the best fried chicken in
New York just put out here all the time
I've been doing it all my life and but
people tell me that it really makes me
feel happy it's amazing I never thought
it would be like this
[Music]
you